hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com so for those who see me for
the first time who let me quickly
introduce myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong and i just started
guys to make youtube videos
because i want to explain how protraders
actually working and
how they make money on the markets so
i'm gonna here talk about all the
different tools and techniques that i
like to use
that work for me and most importantly
guys i want to show you
how to use it yourself so today i'm
gonna make an
update on gme let's get into it
[Music]
and guys so for those who watched my
previous videos
i'm here on the four hours time frame so
let's start actually on the hourly time
frame and i just sum up quickly what
happened the past few days
so we had this massive dip on the
earnings then uh the market
just came back right away doing a
beautiful one two three four five and we
arrived
at this resistance level that i showed
you guys how to find
just by connecting the two recent highs
that you had in the previous
move down and this resistance got broken
re-tested perfectly guys and i told you
this i told you that this is the way
things work so we broke it we retested
it and now
we are wondering what is happening so
guys i'm here to explain
the different scenarios what we expect
what we are looking for
and what we see on the hourly time frame
guys you are seeing this so usually when
you have a breakout of
um you know a strong move down like this
as i said before
you need a little bit of time for the
damage to be fixed
for all this fear to be gone of the
market before the market
can start being really bullish again so
we need
time basically for people to accept this
new situation
so we expect some more consolidation
this is very normal we can even have
maybe a deep coming like around the 175
or even below this wouldn't be unusual
guess this trend line will act as
support
all way up that is happening right now
and we are looking for some
resistance and some support so the
supports level are still the same
175 and to find the resistance guys you
need
to find trend lines or moving averages
that have the best reactions
so here i did it in terms of trendline i
didn't find
much but in terms of moving average i
found something quite interesting
so on the hourly timeframe actually you
don't see it guys that's why you need to
switch
you know you go to the four hours the
four hours is very good guys because
it's used by
a lot of investors so you usually find a
lot of nice
reactions on this time frame so once
again always have the
all the 20 50 200 even the 100 period
moving average if you want
you can put it like simple which is
arithmetical average
or exponential average whatever you want
you need to find those
that have the best reactions and here
guys look so the 15
period moving average on the four hours
time frame is actually here
giving me one reaction here and two
reactions here and here all right
so this is the area that is actually
acting as resistance right now
so i expect this keeping acting as
resistance
the support is 175 it can be also here
so the support area is not that clear
for me so what we expect is actually the
price to consolidate maybe a bit more
maybe too deep you know
and suddenly to just blow up on the
upside
you know because we expect to move up so
i'm not saying we're not gonna break
here maybe we're gonna go slightly below
but ultimately i expect a strong move up
now in terms of
when so this is a very good question i
think that it's gonna arrive
before the 16th of april so my target
for the very short term let's say is
around like you know
300 480 like this area
this would make sense for me once again
guys this is my idiot waves counting i'm
not gonna do it again
here with you go check my other videos
if you are interested
but discounting is telling me that now
we're gonna have the third wave
that is probably gonna arrive around the
480 level i think
within like two three weeks so
why two three weeks let me show you you
go
on yahoo finance everybody has yahoo
finance
it's public data you type gme
so here you have a lot of information
and what i'm interested in
is the options so you click here on
options
and here you're gonna have a lot of data
that you guys probably don't understand
and don't know how to read
that's why i'm here all right so here
you have the different maturities
and you can see that there are even for
april you have
four five maturities but only one is
actually important guys
it's like you know the listed one the
most used ones
it's the one where you're gonna have the
more open interest and it's the 16th of
april
which is true for all u.s stocks i'm an
option trader once again this is my job
so i know about the stuff and i'm
telling you so just use it as a fact
you go on 16 of april and here guys
you have every row is an option
this column is very important is the
strike so you can
scroll down what i'm what i'm interested
in is the
big strikes and you can see that on the
800 strike
you have 25 000 options
that are traded already at this level
once i have this so i compute all this
data i showed you guys this but i want
to show you again
i'm going to update you guys with this
data because you know i just each time
there is a new number i put it here
so here my new number is here 25 000 and
i compute all of them i take all the
maturities i did this
and i come up with this charts all right
and this
is actually showing you guys the total
open
interest in terms of national go check
my video i show
everything how i compute it that i
uploaded like yesterday or two days ago
but here what i'm interested to show you
guys is that now the national
grew from 2.5 billion when i did this
video a few days ago
to 3.5 billion so there is more people
buying this 800 call options
on the april maturity 16th of april
may june july so on and so forth
especially those four actually
so this is telling me that if gme goes
higher
there's going to be around the 16th of
april a very very big gamma
in the market which is gonna make very
bullish dynamics on the stock price if
the stock goes higher
this is only true if we go close to the
strike
but what is hundred percent sure guys is
that this day on the 16th of april
this is the option expiry and you have
options everywhere you know so you have
it under 800 strikes but you have it
under 200 300 400
and this day is going to be a big big
day where the market is going to move a
lot
you're going to see that and so i expect
my scenario to happen before that day
you know because i'm looking for a
strong move up so something
very powerful so i think that this day
might be the day it happens
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show see you guys